hey 42 here 385 million years ago fish
had fingers welcome to RIF half of all
human beings have mites living in their
eyelashes the average Internet user goes
online
34 times a day the cast of Riverdance
have worn out 14 thousand pairs of shoes
cruise ships have morgues on board
roughly 200 people died on cruise ships
each year most deaths are due to old age
so most ships have small morgues that
can store up to 10 bodies the design for
the Guy Fawkes mask commonly wore by
anonymous protesters fighting against
government and corporate corruption is
owned by Time Warner ironically Time
Warner gets a percentage of the profits
every time one of the masks is sold in
response to a question from a
five-year-old the Royal Mail has
calculated that it will cost eleven
thousand six hundred and two pounds and
twenty five pence to send a letter to
Mars the floods in Australia in 2010 and
2011 caused the world's sea levels to
drop by seven millimetres for 87 years
the Portuguese kept the existence of the
ascention Islands a secret from the rest
of the world if the earth had no clouds
the sea would completely evaporate in
19th century Britain prisoners were let
out for the day if they paid a small fee
of 5 pounds roughly 300 pounds in
today's money human beings had been
keeping sheep for 7,000 years before it
occurred to anyone to use their wool if
everyone washed their hands properly
with soap
it would save 600,000 lives a year
during its lifetime the International
Space Station will be hit by 100,000
meter
during World War two many German
soldiers used steroids to make
themselves more aggressive the
first-ever motor insurance policy issued
by Lloyds of London described the car as
a ship navigating on land thanks for the
view subscribe for more 42